but speaking of memes
what the heck do you think is up with
elon musk talking about
dogecoin a lot sort of uh from the
cryptocurrency community
i uh from that i've been talking to a
lot of
sort of technologists i guess and
reading papers on cryptocurrency
it's like nobody really sees
dogecoin as a revolutionary crypto
technology
a lot of people talk about security
issues there's a bunch of issues
it has nevertheless you did say that
money
is the kind of uh social construct right
and uh elon musk's combination of humor
and brilliant engineering in the various
companies he runs
combines to create a kind of value
and excitement behind dogecoin it's like
um what is it he says uh that the most
amusing outcome is
is the most likely kind of idea which
sounds silly but there could be like
profound truth to it
it's like what do you make of deutsche
coin philosophically
or technically is is it possible that
dogecoin will overtake bitcoin and run
the entire
run the entire world i can't even
because it could happen
it could happen but what uh if there's
any serious way to answer that question
well we have to start with uh techno
king
of tesla yeah and master of coin
as they are so articulately called in
the latest sec filing
because he officially changed his title
techno king yes techno king of tesla
and now the cfo's new uh title is a
master of coin
and so uh when you have a sense of humor
yeah and frankly uh a level of
uh self-confidence and uh
an element of an appreciation for irony
in the world
dogecoin is actually one of the least
crazy things that you could talk about
when you're willing to go to techno king
of tesla master of coin
and all this stuff and so i think that
elon
doesn't get enough credit frankly for
his understanding of internet culture
understanding of memes and understanding
of frankly
human psychology and marketing and so in
some crazy way
every time he talks about dogecoin it's
a rallying cry for an entire generation
of kids
it's a rallying cry for an entire
industry in terms of cryptocurrencies
and digital technologies
but this is the flag yeah
and this is the thing that he can yell
and scream about
and tweet about without worry of
punishment
so he could be talking about bitcoin he
could be talking about cryptocurrency
but that's not going to be uh as
beautifully
humorous and whatever the hell internet
culture is as
dogecoin he's finding the right language
he's speaking the language of the people
of the in the digital age if you want to
reach weird people
yeah you can't be serious and most
people are weird
the the masses are weird so he's
speaking to the masses
yeah and the techno king and even
further than that i think is
he essentially is um he's using
dogecoin as a way to say
i'm doing this because i can yeah he
couldn't do it
with securities he couldn't do it with
certain types of other assets right
like i almost look at this like a venn
diagram what's the thing that a bunch of
people know about
care about thinkers funny whatever and
also
overlay that with the things that like
he could actually talk about they won't
get in trouble for
that's a big fu to the sec i could see
the
the people just freaking out i i mean i
love it
but um i i don't know if i would have
the guts to do it myself
but i i think he's an inspiration for a
lot of us
to be like well maybe you should grow
the guts when you're the techno king you
can do whatever you want right
[Laughter]
and i mean that's something to aspire to
is to be the techno king in your own
little world
if you also think about it in the sense
of uh when you're somebody on a mission
to create interplanetary
life yeah when you're trying to solve
a or put a dent in the climate crisis
or create electric vehicles and be the
first american company and you know
however long
frankly the sec or
other things in your life that just
don't you don't ascribe that much
importance to compared to those things
they're almost
nuisances and that's scary i think for
shareholders of
a company when the person that you're
trusting to lead you to the promised
land and create shareholder value
doesn't put value on certain things but
at the same time
i always look at it as a tug of war how
much of the actions of what he's doing
and calling attention to actually
changed the way
that regulators lawmakers politicians
countries whatever act he may not be
able to say
do axe i'm the techno king and they go
do it
but with every step he makes he
changes some of their behavior and so i
think that it's um
a really kind of game of like 3d chess
that frankly i'm not privy to right i'm
kind of watching from the sidelines and
uh figuring out alongside everybody else
but i also don't think that it's just
elon
uh bought a bunch of dogecoin and tweets
about it because he thinks he's going to
a dollar and he's gonna you know make
money right like i don't think
i don't think it's an economic argument
as to why he's so interested in it i
think it's much more
uh it's almost like meta message
for a lot of other stuff yeah he's kind
of uh trying to break apart
internet communication from first
principles like he does so many other
problems it's kind of fascinating to
watch i know he's been
uh he's he's taught me quite a bit about
communication
and uh at least for me
it's been liberating to not give a
[ __ ] about the old school way of things
i've been always bothered by
a place i deeply admire which is mit but
there's
problems the bureaucracies and
hierarchies that hold back innovation
brilliant minds
and in that sense doge is a kind of fu
to the system that's kind of positive
but also
uh kind of uh but it was also an
fu
you